der schweres busunglück in mexiko ist es
kurz nach halb elf als der notruf in der
rettungsstelle eingeht einen
muldenkipper und ein reisebus chorlied
kollidieren in der nähe des dorfes
elftal bei kranken der busse überschlägt
sich minutenlang hilferufe und dann
verstummen sie es gibt tote und
verletzte und wie jetzt bekannt wird
auch aus deutschland
eine reise in mexiko endet im tragischen
unglück der bus der linie 04 89 ist auf
dem weg von cancún nach merida um 10 uhr
30 die katastrophe
diese frau ist eine der überlebenden
blutüberströmt ruft sie nachhilfe hinter
ihrem bus eingeklemmte menschen eine
zeugin es war schockierend und
beunruhigen denn wir konnten nichts
anderes tun als auf die rettungskräfte
zu warten acht tote darunter ein
neunjähriges mädchen und 20 verletzte
jetzt die traurige gewissheit unter den
toten ist eine deutsche touristin
zwei weitere deutsche werden schwer
verletzt
[Musik]
urlaubsparadies sollte es sein und dann
war es der tod von den 45 passagieren an
bord wurde also acht getötet 20 verletzt
zehn davon sehr schwer über diesen
tragischen unfall wollen wir jetzt mit
unserer bild reporterin vor ort seegras
rainer sprechen sie ist live in mexiko
und uns zugeschaltet guten rang sechs
es ist noch dunkel bei euch wie man
sieht wilke weiß man inzwischen wie es
zu dem tragischen unglück gekommen ist
augenzeugen berichten davon dass ein
kipplaster aus einer baustelle auf die
autobahn aufgefahren ist und zwar ohne
auf den verkehr zu achten und den
busfahrer kam schon so nah dran dass er
nicht mehr bremsen konnte möglicherweise
ist da auch erhöhte geschwindigkeit mit
dem spiel gewesen dass dort noch zu
sehen
das wird die staatsanwaltschaft noch
herausfinden
müssen genau die verantwortung hat beide
fahrer sind vorläufig festgenommen aber
es sieht eher danach aus dass der fahrer
des kippers das hier den vorteil
ich stehe hier an der bundesstraße 180
die nachgang kunden hört also hierher
der bus gefahren
es ist nicht irgendeine baustelle
sondern auf der ganzen strecke 250
kilometer lang von hier nach cancun wird
derzeit der tränen maja gebaut der wie
maya bahn das vorzeigeprojekt des
aktuellen präsidenten
da wird die ganze autobahn von 40 auch
richtig meter breite erweitert plus eine
bahnstrecke daneben reporter zeit diese
baustelle wird uns noch lange
beschäftigen in den nächsten drei jahren
und silke kannst du uns schon ein
bisschen mehr über die deutschen opfer
berichten
ja es handelt sich bei der toten um eine
20 jährige deutsche die leider durch
schon an der unfallstelle verstorben ist
und dann gibt es noch zwei weitere junge
männer die verletzt wurden für den einen
ist das ganze glimpflich ausgegangen er
konnte gestern schon aus dem krankenhaus
entlassen werden und wird heute nach
deutschland zurückkehren der andere
liegt noch im krankenhaus und es wird
aber möglicherweise auch in den nächsten
tagen schon entlassen wir wissen dass
alle drei zusammen gesessen haben und
nicht kannten und so auf den ganz
hinteren plätzen gesessen haben aber
alle eben verschiedene arten von
verletzungen haben und
das heißt jetzt auch nicht unbedingt
dass wenn man hinten gesessen hat ein
größeres risiko
informationen von silke gras rainer live
aus mexiko vielen dank dafür